[Musique]
ces deux jours après les attentats de
bruxelles d'accord je suis chez moi à la
maison j'ai un ami qui me propose
d'aller chercher un pote à frère à lui
donc à l'aéroport je devais aller
chercher parce que les avions étaient
déroutés vers liège avait plus d'avion
qui descendait à bruxelles on est pris
en filature par la police
on le savait pas et là d'un coup une
voiture banalisée débarquent par la
gauche
une autre en cercle et là je n'ai pas le
temps de réaliser ça va mais ça va très
vite en fait donc pas le temps de voir
les brassards et c'est moi je me suis
content j'ai vu une chose c'est un
policier en face de moi avec une
mitraillette et donc vraiment un fusil
d'assaut qui me faisait et qui me
tremblay et moi je suis là et un silence
de mort bien cherché et je me lycée mais
c'est la fin je vais mourir en fait ils
sont autour de moi et une vise avec
leurs armes
et là il me demande de mettre au sol et
il son édition toujours autour de moi
avec une distance je comprends pas et
donc il me met des bandeaux sur les yeux
et on est emmené manu militari un parent
dans des voitures
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là
quand vous arrivez au comice alors ça va
durer des heures
je vais pas savoir ce que c'est donc
fouille au corps et la transférer dans
un dans un dans une cellule et je vois
plein de flics c'est parce qu'on est con
à ce moment là qu on vous soupçonne
d'être un des auteurs des à mon père
n'en sais tu sais ce que tu as fait mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
j'ai fait tu sais très bien ce que tu as
fait
quatre jours après les attentats vous
allez donc être arrêté de l'inculpé à
deux jours à raison le tapissage ce fait
il ya un chronomètre de l'avocat me ma
forme parce que l'avocat est avec le
taximan derrière la vitre sans tain et
il ya un chronomètre là ils ont bien
fait les choses et il a reconnu en
quelques secondes
ouais c'est oui je confirme 700% que
c'est lui croire ce moment là la machine
s'emballe clairement je retourne donc le
juge macule pas partir de ce moment là
quand je suis dans la voiture et chant
menée chez le juge d'instruction les
dans la voiture du retour à la radio
fayçal chef ou terroristes je me dis
mais qu'est ce qui se passe et on dit
ouais mais ton nom est déjà été balancé
je suis transféré en prison
donc on me dit c'est bon mandat d'arrêt
est là quand j'arrive en prison les
gardiens passé ces cinq terroristes et
c'est même pareil quand j'étais pendant
les 48 heures au commissariat
c'est yves le clapet salle terroristes
de merde t'as tué plus de trente deux
personnes on va rester ici tu vas tu
tu vas jamais sortir d'ici et c'est des
insultes delhommeau chapeau assassins
criminels salle jihadi d'abord il faut
qu'il a fait sur la chose c'est que j'ai
pas mangé
on m'a ramené un plâtre et il était
bourré de crachats et on voyait les
crachats dessus alors il mais qu'est-ce
que vous ne sais quoi ça ne fera rien
d'autre et je suis resté ce que j'ai
perdu 7 kilos on se rentrait chez moi et
je découvre sur une chaîne de télévision
fayçal chiffres ou à laser libérer ça et
là une heure plus tard il toque et me
dit nettoie la cellule délibéré
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous êtes vous
avez été libérés ab les preuves ne sont
pas conforté par l' enquête c'est tout
ce que je sais et les médias ont joué là
dessus certains me direz chiant à jouer
comment ça se fait que fayçal chef ont
été libérés le troisième terroriste qui
était inculpé etc mais reste inculpé des
trois chefs d'inculpation les plus
graves de belgique etc et les mêmes
chefs d'inculpation que le véritable
terroriste du coup je suis là est-ce que
vous avez été dédommagés annonce jusqu'à
présent dont 0,1 mais je viens en fait
de sa frappe et cinq ans le 5 janvier
j'ai reçu des excuses officielles de la
justice est une bien avant car ils m'ont
dit clairement on vous considère comme
aussi à une des victimes des attentats
de bruxelles quand on m'a dit ça et
qu'on m'a dit que j'étais c'était pas
moi quoi c'est comme si on m'avait
retiré un sac de 200 kg de mes épaules
cinq ans j'ai dû me balader avec ça ou
dans la formule du chapeau c'est en fait
mohamed abri mais voilà voilà il a été
arrêté huit jours après qu'on met a
annoncé mais je m'en foutais je sais que
c'est pas moi